man i love cheese
[Laughter]
hey guys welcome back to big mood
today who do we have here i feel like
we've been forgetting to introduce
ourselves so let's do that again who do
we have starting on this side i'm nikki
i'm gina and then i'm tiff all right
tiff what did you bring for us oh my
gosh i surprised everyone
with this beautiful amazing charcuterie
board
it was so beautiful and we just like
dove into it before it
just showed so it's completely wrecked
right now
but it looked beautiful before gorgeous
so shout outs to my cheesy passion thank
you doreen
we'll show a beautiful picture of what
it looked like yes before before we
wrecked it well
maybe like my stories because that's the
one time that we got something and it
was like on my story
so you're seeing this thing did not
survive more than two seconds in this
video you're doing a charcuterie board
to a panel of girls right
women yeah so if you guys are interested
check out my cheesy passion
doreen makes amazing short crew boards
whoa i had trouble with that one
charcuterie in the la
area yes la area thanks babe thank you
those are so good
it's like so i have this thing where
like i have to try different foods
so when i go to a restaurant i never
know what i want because i want to try
everything yeah me too but this is
literally just trying like sixteen
hundred different things
once yeah oh my god i do i have to talk
about this
my most favorite favorite favorite thing
on this entire board is this
weird thing in the middle i think it's
goat cheese with a rolled and blueberry
and honey it is
you can get it to it it's delicious
i need it anyways today's episode
i wanted to get into like a dating topic
because you know that's the only thing
that
is relevant to me i'm not married like
these other [ __ ] well neither is gina
but
gina doesn't really care about men or
anything right now
but for me i i've been spending a lot of
time reading stuff
online and like actually taking the time
to think about what i want in a
relationship where i've kind of gone
wrong over the years
what i can do looking forward i'm not
actively dating anyone right now i've
deleted all of my
dating apps i'm taking a hardcore break
during covet i feel like it's the best
time to take that kind of break yeah but
there was an idea
kind of introduced to me in all the
stuff that i was reading and it's this
idea of
like a high value partner versus a low
value partner and i have to say i've
never really
thought about that dating like
consciously like is this a high value
person or is this a low value person
like that seems kind of a little bit
you know well shitty no
because i know what you're getting at
but the real definition of high value
partner it really is like for you
yeah i value for like for me like
exactly value
this part or like whatever this person's
life is like it it complements my
life completely well that's the high
value part because then it's easily
um misconstrued to be like oh you're
mature materialistic like yeah
really rich yeah superficial but no it's
high value
to the person yeah so i wanted to get
away from thinking oh high value just
means that you know he has a lot of
money and
blah blah and he has six pack abs and
stuff like that that's kind of like not
the direction
yeah that i'm trying to take because
that's what you're looking i mean unless
that is what you value and i do value
that
ladies and gentlemen but that's not
going to necessarily get me the right
partner it's like you could be a rhombus
and be a square but you can't be a
square and a
you know what's a rhombus the [ __ ] is a
rhombus
square that's like crooked it's yeah
well like yeah like a rectangle that's
crooked i forget which one it is
but it's basically this is for are you
smarter than me
listen you it's basically there's a
category and a square fits in it
but then like it doesn't go the other
way yeah exactly he doesn't necessarily
this is too much [ __ ] math listen get
out of here i like math
i like math i like cheese i like oh my
gosh
[Laughter]
i like money and six-pack what's me
i guess this is weird now because i used
to think that only certain girls went
after like
people that have money or like looks but
uh
and then like the majority were like
more like me where like they go after
personality
but now like as after being in the world
for a while i'm like
oh no like a lot of people go after like
looks and
and money i i've never thought about it
especially like
in big cities like in la where like
tinder
like all these dating apps are like a
huge thing it's like we have
like 10 million people in the greater
los angeles
area and a lot of them are single and a
lot of them are all in these apps and
they're constantly swiping for the next
upgrade and it's all
just what's your job and what do you
look like and so
i think people aren't really taking the
time to consider like
anything at all it's just who's the
hottest and then like who has the most
money or whatever so i feel like
having a discussion i'm like that's
probably not the best way to date yeah
yeah you know it's like because i mean
career could be very
important i mean obviously it's a very
important factor in someone's life
because
let's say i want someone that can travel
with me all over the place all over the
world but then they're
this this like real really busy finance
person that's constantly
in meetings or whatever then that that
wouldn't be high value to me right even
though they make six figures or
something
it's not adding value to your life
because you're stuck at home like they
can never vacation
they couldn't share your lifestyle or
what like invigorates you
that's true yeah that's why i think that
you should always pick someone
that you can be best friends with i
think people overlook that a lot
like and i don't know why because like
you if you picture how you're going to
be spending
your life with somebody like wouldn't
you want to be best friends and like
have them be cool to hang out with i i
couldn't
i can't imagine hanging out with someone
that long that just
doesn't well that's that's when it
really does matter though like what is
high value to you because then let's say
i'm
the type of person that i will be the
happiest if i
just get left alone and i have a mansion
and um it's so good this like
i'm down just left alone in a mansion at
this point i'm like that sounds like and
then like my husband
is just like an [ __ ] but it's okay i
don't have to deal with him because he's
not around that much
and i don't value his presence or
whatever the [ __ ]
i don't know other people could have
those type of values yeah that was
interesting
so yeah i guess it's uh to me
i mean like i'm not gonna be a
gatekeeper of what defines a
relationship but it seems unhealthy
um i'm down for the best friend thing
too like my best relationship ever is
when he and i are best friends
yeah just sit around just do dumb [ __ ]
together and have the greatest time
or even if you're not best friends
because that's how i operate too but at
least someone that
you you guys have the same values in
life like the same
um visions of how you want your future
to be like
true so i guess if you were with that
really rich guy maybe that guy has to
like having a wife that doesn't really
want his presence around
yeah yeah there's one of my favorite um
like sugar baby relationships is on the
real housewives of beverly hills
and it's um this lady her name's erica
gerardi but she goes by erica jane and
she's like a total sugar baby like her
husband's like 80 or 90 years i mean
[ __ ] the [ __ ] dude as old as [ __ ] but
he's rich as [ __ ] and i'm like
that's kind of cool but also she does
have to sleep with them so i don't know
about that
but that's basically that lifestyle
you're talking about like she values
money husband yeah
security values having a [ __ ] ton of
money to do whatever she wants
and he's just like this old bastard
that's he's
he seems like a sweet guy but he's just
old as [ __ ] i've dated someone before
who like
on paper you would think that it checks
all the boxes and it's cool
but that's and then i realized this is
not my paper like these are not
the whites what else is paper whose
paper is this
with the wrong name like made good money
stable and all that [ __ ] but then
then i realized i was like i don't see
you as like my friend
you know like you're kind of boring
power dynamic
is really weird too especially i think
for girls like us too because we don't
really like
roll over and take [ __ ] yeah exactly so
like having someone having
all the money and then telling you what
to do like i think when you're young
you're like 21 you're like oh i'll be a
sugar baby yeah so
it's easy but then if you actually try
anything like that or if you get into a
relationship that's like don't like
they're so
dominant with money um it's really not
like good in the long
run yeah i think that's why i never went
that route because i hated
that when i lived with my parents my dad
got to make all the rules cause he paid
the bills or whatever so
from as young as i can remember i've
always tried to make my own money
because i didn't like having to ask for
money or be controlled by somebody or
if i if i ask for money now it's like i
owe them a favor
or something like that just commenting
on it because like in my relationship
with joe
um i like he would we would just be
talking and he would be telling me what
investments he was doing or whatever and
i would be like well i don't know if i
i don't know if that's a good idea or
whatever and then it would just create
an issue because you'd be like well it's
not
your place to comment you know and so
i'm like all right well damn [ __ ] that
i think you can't you know i don't even
know i'm like all right whatever your
money do whatever the [ __ ] you want with
it i don't care
but yeah also on the on another note
though
in that vein like i do see myself moving
towards like i'm getting my cpa license
and like
the idea of like dating someone that's
also in finance or just an accountant or
something like that i mean that does
feel like it could work for me too um
but i'm not sure yet because i haven't
met anyone yeah you guys can do
spreadsheets together
it sounds really [ __ ] fun at your
house i'm sexy oh my god you guys can
do addition multiplications in bed
together what the [ __ ] addition and
multiplications yeah
we could talk about the new all the
pemdas
and stuff it's so hot i love it so much
i love excel
no joke i have a friend couple uh and
they've been together for a long time
and
they are so compatible and they [ __ ]
come
all over spreadsheets they love
spreadsheets
they come all over oh yeah like it gets
them wet it gets
the morning of their house and you guys
have like spreadsheet or a presentation
oh yes they'll do that oh no no no
that's that's our
like more comedian they're really fun
it's like
in the pyramid scheme selling knives
[ __ ] is this watch it
so what's it called powerpoint um so
every valentine's day our friends
our other friends are separate not that
i'm sorry i got them confused i have
seen those stories
there's the powerpoint friends they do
themed parties and
everyone puts together a powerpoint
presentation on whatever subject you
want
and so it ends up being really funny
because everyone there is a comedian
and so it's like like they get really
serious about the dumbest
[ __ ] it's really funny it's fun actually
yeah so i think my last one was about
how um the illuminati created animal
crossing to keep everyone in a pandemic
and it was like a whole conspiracy you
made a powerpoint presentation oh yeah
why haven't you sent that title
oh you had to be part of the party oh
i'm sorry i need to get really drunk to
listen
i'm totally down for this next get
together well i know you're going to
have some sort of a picnic or a barbecue
or something oh yeah some sort of
barbecue barbecue something you know
here's why redheads are better
than everyone anyone that has a redhead
yo we're actually having a big mood
thing maybe we could do powerpoint
presentations
uh in in gina fashion i will be late and
i will not be uh
turning in anything in time yeah someone
else is going okay sometimes he's gonna
do it for me to be honest
if you want to do her homework for her
that wasn't me i was i was on gina's
program too we didn't find out about the
party until last minute so both steve
and i did it in like 30 minutes before
the
party started but i will have to say i
work really well under pressure
cute and i did a pretty good powerful
presentation
but no the other couple their
spreadsheet couple and they
are just they fit really well like they
love
making spreadsheets and that's something
that i've never
found i've never like looking back i'm
like
i've never really fully just like fit
with the person that i was dating i feel
like
there was always a reason why i wanted
to date them but i
it i never connected it to like oh this
works for me
yeah my personality and it's weird to
now look back and be like wait
every single person i dated like it was
never a good fit
yeah it's like i've never dated like try
to force it yeah it's like when you're
doing a puzzle
and there's a piece that looks like it
would fit and like
but it doesn't quite fit but you want it
to fit so bad so you just keep [ __ ]
the time like the longer you are with
someone eventually you're forcing it
yeah yeah yes we do not want to jam
things together
circles and squares yeah so i guess what
would be the first step
to determining what's a high value
partner to you
so um well obviously it's like actually
knowing who you are
yeah because i think that was a big
problem too i i never really sat
back to think like who am i without the
influence of the people around me what
things do i actually really like
i know you can relate to that because
you've kind of been steadily in
a relationship for a long time i
freaking
loved shan's book shan buchanan
her book game of desire it it literally
talks about all of that
and she actually gives you like
worksheets so you can get to know
yourself and your own preferences and
what is
high value to you and she talks about
that like finding someone that actually
fits in there
like a like a puzzle piece to your life
rather than the way
i think for sure me the way i would view
partners was like oh do they like me am
i okay for you like
or like they haven't i cater to you yeah
i think for me like
i i kind of would go for the bad boys a
lot
um or like if there was just sexual
chemistry not even considering
anything outside of that so hard because
very dangerous
oh my god good sex can trap you i was
watching love island she called it dick
sand
and i'm like oh my [ __ ]
trapped in dick sand for 30 well known i
didn't
start dating until i was like 18. so for
whatever 33 minus 18 years
i've literally teen [ __ ] math whiz
over there i can't do my deal
i like math i like math and i'm the
[ __ ] one getting my cpa license weird
anyways i will not trust you with my
accounts no i think those we've used a
calculator so much that i forgot to use
my brain but anyways
that's a cpa so i just ran the other way
i've literally been
in dick sand my whole life so i'm
actually really proud of myself that i'm
gonna get out of dick sand
you're brushing off the granules i'm
brushing off
and you're getting to your actual
scanning you're getting to know yourself
yes getting to know myself and then one
thing is like
um so there's probably like a list of
qualities that are also very basic in
general that i've overlooked like
is he generally respectful to you to
your time to your desires and needs
because i've been in a lot of
relationships where the guys
um they will kind of complain when i ask
them to do something
they will like not be respectful of my
friends or like they'll make little
comments where like because i'm always
the girl that has like the dark humor
the quips or whatever like they'll do
things that are almost
cutting but then they'll be like what i
thought you were the funny girl
you know so there's like there's like
some weird things with respect sometimes
with men
that i never really considered before
and i get trapped in the dick sand and
i'm like
yeah and you don't want to be uncool
yeah you don't want to show like you're
not cool with this
type of humor so i would think
definitely like
in looking for a higher value partner
it's like is he actually respectful
like the baseline [ __ ] like that i think
a lot of girls are forgetting to do you
know
true um because that dick sans so
powerful it is
yeah i know it's i feel spoiled because
uh so i was
in those type of relationships for a
while too and then steve completely
180 all of that and and i am so in love
with him and he fits
he's the only person that's ever like
fit the puzzle completely that made me
go like oh
[ __ ] why was i forcing that other piece
so long like i really thought i couldn't
find anything that fit
you know close enough so i was like
willing to settle on close enough um
but yeah he fit perfectly and um and the
way that he treats me
when i see people not getting treated
that way or not getting that level of
respect
i'm actually blown away now where i'm
like how dare he not do this for you or
whatever
i'm like oh [ __ ] am i spoiled because
he's like
so sweet and thoughtful like i'll be
upstairs editing
and he'll come in and i'm like i'm busy
and he'll he's like i'm just trying to
check in if your water bottle is full
enough
and oh my water bottle then i melt and
then we
then we kiss his stuff oh he's such a
little [ __ ]
i'm trying to think if i've ever dated
anyone that would do anything remotely
close to that and i'm
maybe one guy might have a little bit
but
gosh no it just seems so rare i'm like
are 90
of men [ __ ] [ __ ] well i had
someone like that
like by far like probably the best guy
ever dated but
it all comes down to also where you guys
are going in your life and what your
your your goals and values are and
that's where we differed
everything else was [ __ ] incredible
but then like talking about the future
he just wasn't there so that didn't work
out yeah that's true because it doesn't
it does the actions if like if it was by
a guy that i wasn't that into
it doesn't matter what their actions are
because i'm just not into them and by
the way
uh i just want to backtrack a little bit
because i don't ask steve to do any of
this
he just does that and it's so super
sweet and he did this
before we were dating too when i was
just a friend he would do that to anyone
any girl here
he would make sure your drinks are
refilled he's very very thoughtful
but um i think that if i wasn't
attracted or something was missing
because i had another boyfriend in the
past who was very thoughtful like that
too but
i just wasn't attracted to him i
couldn't put my finger on it
but he would just annoy me so i'd be
like i could get my own water so maybe
he's
more of like a clinger like yes like yes
to where you don't
you already kind of don't respect him as
a man like as an individual
unit and so he's just like doing extra
[ __ ] and you're like oh stop
and he would also i felt like he was
doing things to get reciprocated
instead of just because he wanted i
think that's a huge red flag
i hate that yeah nice guys right yes
and then like oh they finish last right
well you're not really nice if you
are doing the nice thing just to get a
nice thing back and then you
hold it against them when you don't get
exactly what you want back
i'm wondering if that's like where a
part of that like mgtow
thing is coming from is guys who were
trying to be nice
and then they [ __ ] got burned yeah
that's because their intentions were
shady to begin with so that's why i
didn't pan out for them yeah
that's exactly what it is it's like hey
i saw your bra
your sure love bra i saw your throat
there's a gap in between there there's
gaps
you have a gap in between you're all bra
i am wearing my third look
no i knew what was happening but i'm
like it's not me guys
it's me guys i forgot like i am actually
wearing my third
is the one wearing the third love bra so
we're looking at tip all right
well i'm wearing a strap listen up
ladies and gentlemen i was nice to you
show me your bra
anyone with boobies out there this bra
is
the best bra i have ever had before i
would go to
places and buy a generic fitting bra
thinking
all bras are like that well guess what
not all bras man not all bras bra
you could get a bra that actually fits
your boobies and
how you do this through third love is
you go online
you take a little quiz about your
current bra situation current
trouble areas you've been having for me
it was always this like
gap in between my boob and the cup and i
just my problem too yeah i thought
that's that's probably and
also when you wash the bras and then
that gap right there it turns
it starts to like curl out oh yeah so
i'm like what the heck
and anytime i would wash anything i'd be
like really am i just
i don't know how to do laundry i started
blaming myself for these toxic ass bras
and then i found third love and they
solved all of my problems i
no longer have that gap i no longer have
straps falling off
so many people are wearing bras that
don't actually fit them and they don't
even know it
and so i didn't i didn't know it so i
went on a third love i took their quiz
they have so many different sizes too
they have over 80 bra sizes
but know that only one that matter the
only one that matters is yours
um there's a perfect fit promise too so
every customer has 60 days to wear it
wash it put it to the test
and if you don't love it you can return
it and third level wash and donate it to
a woman in need
which is awesome um it's the most
comfortable bra you've ever owned so
third love knows there's a perfect bra
for everyone right now they're offering
our listeners
15 off your first order go to
thirdlove.com
big mood now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15
off your first purchase that's
thirdlove.com
big mood for 15 off today 15. use it
and i i got the i got the strapless and
it works really good this is my
most favorite strapless i need a shirt
owned in my entire life because
every time i've owned a strapless bra it
always slips down yeah always
not this one hell yeah that's awesome
yeah you know what else is awesome
life life is like life is awesome gina
gina's mouth is just hanging wide open
she likes cheese i like blueberries
anyways
um well so have you guys noticed things
are getting a little bit better in the
world like we're kind of able to get
back out
slowly we're able to go to restaurants a
little bit you know keeping the whole
thing
um in consideration but like slowly we
get to see our friends and family again
pretty soon hopefully by next year we'll
actually get to see our friends and
family
in person in person and if you start
right now
by then you can have perfectly straight
teeth with who
with candid candid uh clear aligners
they're comfortable removable and
totally
invisible and unlike those horrible wire
braces
sorry if you have wire braces they are
horrible they know they know how
difficult they are so with candid you
could transform your smile without
anyone noticing
plus your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan
so you'll never have to wonder how
you're doing you'll always know
the average candid treatment is just six
months and you'll start seeing results
way before then start straightening your
teeth today right now all of our
listeners can save 75
on candid starter kit go to candidco.com
mood and use code mood that's
candidco.com
mood code mood take advantage of this
limited time offered save seventy five
dollars on your starter kit
candidco.com mood with the code mood
yeah that's a lot of doll here 75
dollars
that's a lot yes it is a lot i like math
i like cheese
so i was reading the article that just
sent us about high value
people have high value partners and
there's some
in there that's like it's so obvious and
it makes
so much sense but i like nikki said some
people just forget
that people should be like that's you
you deserve someone good like
um a low value partner is someone that
would pick you up after you drink with
your friends all night and drive you
home but the whole time they're
complaining
you know and instead of like wanting to
to know that you got home safely like oh
i'm happy to make sure you got home
safely exactly
like come on bro but a high value be
like oh do you need a ride yeah
absolutely i'll drive home i'll drive
your friends home too if you need to
and i love people like that but some
like a lot of times people just overlook
these things like oh yeah but
he did pick me up yeah but he was
bitching the whole entire time
yeah yeah it's about adding value to
your life rather than taking it away so
if someone's draining you
and you're just that's obviously like
well they make up for it with this
aspect it's like well they shouldn't be
having to make up for
anything and i think that does come come
down to like knowing yourself because
um i remember when i was single and
living alone and there wasn't many times
in my life that i was single but i was
single for an eight-month period of time
and during that time i thought i was
gonna be single a lot longer because i
was so
happy like with what i had and what i
had built and i was working on my
computer right now i'm kind of like
that right now yeah just now finally
well good just now better late than
never yeah
and um it was it's like well i don't
want this to go away
like i i'd rather be single forever than
have
someone that i have to compromise with
and this be kind of that's this feeling
be drained
um so whoever i date next i'm not
settling they have to add value to this
they have to
um just be something be an extra part of
my life
not something that's that i have to give
up in order to have
it's hard to know like when that's
happening because i know like the
the whole honeymoon phase of meeting
someone new they usually also they're
putting their best face on
totally you're putting your best face on
and also you're drunk off all those
chemicals
that are coursing through your body when
you meet someone that you like so go on
a weekend trip as soon as possible
oh really yeah like go go on a trip
together somewhere
far away like far out of your you know
city so they can murder you in another
country
well hopefully you would know them
better than that how soon as soon as
possible
i'd say a few months in like i'd say i
would date someone for three months if i
had a really good feeling about them
like i really wanted to move things
forward
go on a trip with them then you can see
if you're even compatible to cohabitate
together
because a lot of if you don't want to
get you know move in and take that jump
first a lot of times going on a trip for
four days or so
people's good bad things that they were
trying to cover
they start to come out a little bit
they're bad habits they're annoying
qualities and you can see if that's
something that you can live with or
they say that if if you can travel
together then you can be together if you
can't it's a huge red flag because
you're going through things like
cohabitating and then crappy things that
happen at airports would they lose their
minds yeah so you're putting into steve
is so annoying to travel with well
yes internationally oh but um will you
guys make it work
well now we do cause that we hit that
point in um
well we had gone on many trips before
then so it was fine but this was our
first time traveling out of the country
together
and steve didn't know how to sleep on
the plane and not get jet lag
so he once we landed he was so jet
lagged the entire trip
he would just be complaining about
everything and i'm like we're trying to
enjoy europe
and he and steve are the same he's like
let's go i want to go back to the hotel
and he was just such an a dick i'm like
i want to explore the city
but it was because he was tired and
jet-lagged he wasn't like that at home
like ever
and so and we had already lived together
at that point and i knew we were
compatible
so it was it threw me for a loop but
i would say you know from the trips that
we took when we were on our own time
we're not like
jet lagged or anything uh he was he was
good it would be a good testing area
we did stay at a few hotels here dude
big big red flags um
when me and joe first got together i
think like immediately we went to hawaii
for gio barngio's wedding
yeah and we were just fighting the whole
time like i wasn't good with travel or
in airplanes i get
really mad anxiety i would never take
anything for the anxiety though so i
would just be on the plane like kind of
semi having panic attacks and like super
uncomfortable
i would be like i need water and then
the stewardess couldn't come up and i
would just be like
i need water i need water need water
like i would kind of like just like
[ __ ] complain
like constantly and it would drive him
absolutely [ __ ] bonkers and so we'd
be fighting the whole trip and the whole
thing would just be totally pointless
like it'd ruin the whole i mean i i know
how to travel better now
yeah but yeah that was a huge it's
communication i think
too because like i think steve was is
very similar to you where
when he's in a different place a place
that's unfamiliar to him he does get
more scared and
he's really bad with directions he gets
lost very easily
and so if we're in another country
everything's in a different language
he's
very stressed out and i didn't really
situation with casey
yeah exactly the same because without
fail before every trip
almost every trip not so much in recent
years but the beginning
holy crap every single trip we would
fight before the trip
during the the traveling of getting
there and then once we're there we're
like trying to settle it in
and then like trying to enjoy the place
and we finally
get there to a pleasant place but
the movement like before going on a trip
he's stressed out about all the things
he needs to do he's a workaholic too so
he
yeah he's like just he gets anxious
about knowing that he's going to have to
turn off the work mind and for him he's
not comfortable with that
so then every single time it would be a
gigantic old fight
but like he said it is a communication
thing because um you know i've been in
situations where like they would get
annoyed and just like you know why why
why don't you know how to do this and
then i would have to instead of me
getting angry i'll be like listen
you need to not be mean to me right now
because i'm learning this is
completely new to me you were new to
something too i'm uncomfortable in this
situation right now so i need you to
understand this is why i feel this way
so it's a big
communication thing is great
communication yeah i'm actually the mean
one
i'm actually the mean one because he's
you're like joe yeah like he's so
like anxious or whatever he's doing and
i didn't realize that that's what was
happening yeah
so then i would and then also me i guess
i'm old-fashioned or whatever but you
know he's the man of the relationship
like he should know where we're going
and whatever like
should know all these things and so i
would use that against him a lot and
obviously i wasn't helpful
and that's the reason why i would get
into a big old fight because then i had
my own ego about it i wasn't
empathetic about the fact that he was
stressed out or whatever new environment
he's thinking about work all these
things
that's why now i think we've gotten a
lot better when it comes to travel
because now i understand like oh he's
just tapping into that part again
i can't take it so personal i have to be
more patient that's why i think sorry
go ahead i love you i love you too oh my
gosh
shout out to somebody how cute that's
the thing with like jess and joe like i
think communication would be a problem
too because
it depends and it's also how joe uh
takes that information because you could
have been like
listen i don't want to be this way but
this is why i feel this way on planes i
don't want to be complaining this whole
entire time i'm just really
uncomfortable so please be patient with
me
and if joe understood then he'll be like
okay
i get that and it's not an ego thing
yeah she's not just bitching at me like
she's this
this is her own thing in her head then
that's good communication yeah no he
just doesn't like to be around bad
energy at all
like that's not whether whether you mean
it or not he's just like oh bad energy
get the [ __ ] out
yeah and i don't feel like that's very
fair because i mean i felt
like that before too but then i realized
people could be going through something
you know like you can't control this i
remember i was going through a thing
like i had like a
uh kind of like a full-on like anxiety
attack and my partner was just like
well you know like why are you acting
like this and then i had to
in the middle of my anxiety attack had
to explain bro
this is from childhood i can't control
this you need to understand this and i
need
help from you and then that's when
they're like okay they you have to learn
good job
that was great communication it's hard
and i've only discovered like i've only
learned how to do all this within the
last like year and a half you know same
same with
like or a little longer but yeah like
same with us like we're trying to figure
out how to communicate and it's all
through therapy
they actually teach you how to analyze
yourself and what you're going through
and what
led you to the point that you're at now
yeah and then to clearly communicate
that
it's a struggle man yeah i guess
communication then is another one
like respect one communication number
two like willingness
actually to communicate though because
i've dated a lot of guys where like
they'll listen to like my problem or
whatever my
qualm is with them or or the situation
but then they're not willing to really
talk through it or take any blame for
their part
or anything like that it's just kind of
like ugh you know like women
you have to be receptive like you can
you can hear them but you're not
necessarily listening
you know like it's just another woman
nagging at you but you have to kind of
take it into consideration too and that
i mean both sides has to do that
so i wonder if you can go from being a
low value partner to a high value
because a lot of this
is maturity with growth i think yeah or
if you're not like
a self-centered [ __ ] yeah right you
can grow out of it yeah
yeah because a lot of this like the way
gina was able to articulate her emotions
um you know a lot of us weren't raised
being able to do that and i think it's
you know fairly
this new generation it's kind of a newer
thing to be able to
learn how to uh that emotional iq the eq
and learn how to articulate all that and
i know um
a lot of statistically men are it's
harder for them to
uh understand their emotions too because
they're taught from a young age to like
kind of hide that [ __ ]
um so yeah it's been interesting with
with steve sometimes he'll be mad
or scared and he won't know why and we
have to delve into it together
whereas before he would just kind of
shut it off like he would just be a wall
and um and slowly he's opened up and i
think encouraging that that
opening up helps them to like understand
their own emotions so that in the future
when they feel that way they don't just
have an outburst they they learn how to
articulate
and dude just last night casey and i had
a thing where he was
being really like snappy with his
movements very like
clearly there was something going on
with him and i'm like hey are you okay
like passive aggressive and stupid very
very very passive aggressive like
slamming doors or all these things and
i'm like
hey like what's going on like is there
anything you want to talk about like
you're very clearly upset about
something or what are you like i'm a
woman i can understand [ __ ] behavior
what's happening
yeah yeah and then so he was just like
like and
like you said like it's really hard to
especially for
men to really try to figure it out and
be like okay what is wrong with me
why am i upset let me trace it back and
then so through that conversation we
were able to
discover like oh he was just upset
because he didn't feel productive for
the day see like the workman thing he
can't turn it off
but yeah so for that he was mad at
himself he was mad at himself
and he was just like externally i'm like
seeing everyone else
i did that yesterday oh yeah yeah yeah
oh was it yesterday oh my god i was so
mad because um
because i wanted to work out it had been
three days and i had such a good streak
of working out
and it had been three days of not
working out because i
was like really tired and fatigued and i
was like oh no i don't want this to be
something because if
i don't let myself rest then i won't be
able to get over it or
you know whatever if if this is
something i need my body needs to rest
and um it's very hard for me to rest
because i need to be productive
and so i given myself three days and i
was like okay i'm gonna work out today
but the kittens
had all escaped from their little fences
i have a what a group of kittens
what a great problem to have right i was
like these [ __ ] kittens are running
under the treadmill
i can't even say kittens mad it's so
[ __ ] cute kittens
ruining my life your life is a circus
and i love it really is
when they ran into the treadmill and i
was like why don't bother them
treadmills now they're home and so i was
like well i could do an at-home workout
on the computer
but then it was like really hot in my
office by that point because the sun
comes through that window
i just can't work out today and then i
was just so mad that it didn't work out
that i was just like
huffing and puffing in my in my uh
bedroom and then my other cats come over
they're like what's wrong
i'm like leave me alone i need to be
alone
alone right now wow it is really
stressful in your head
this morning i was doing makeup and
steve was like wow woman you are juicy
i'm like i'm not ready yet
don't look at but the new foster kids
are like this [ __ ] is [ __ ] insane i
cannot
they should have just left me in the
[ __ ] place
i feel like we've communicated so well
over the years that he reads my language
like
when i say x it's not i'm not serious
i'm not like
[ __ ] you for saying i'm juicy i'm like
let me be presentable what does
juicy mean anyway he he just like you
got a juicy butt
yeah yeah cause he was looking at me
from behind he likes to take um secret
pictures
of my butt like when i'm
secretly taking pictures okay well no
nudes is my role
but you know he can take anything but
nudes um
but yeah so uh i was doing my makeup and
you know
like i was just flustered because like i
wasn't feeling like my
[ __ ] hair was doing the right thing
you're feeling ugly yes yeah yeah
i do i can't say it but i don't tell me
like i don't want you to have to say
just whenever i ask you because then
you're saying because i ask you but i
want to say yourself
jesus christ so should they be like do
you feel beautiful today
i don't know am i beautiful why do you
want to dance
oh my god why do i not look beautiful to
you what the [ __ ]
you're beautiful now you're saying it
because i asked it doesn't even count
how do they deal with that i don't know
i don't know but you know probably by
playing a video app or a mobile app game
chill because you know best fiends got
your back
it's a great way to ignore your woman
when she's being crazy play games
no don't ignore her kill some time let
her calm down because she
wants a long time period exactly when
she wants alone time bust
out your phone and play some best fiends
which is a mobile puzzle game
and i really i you guys know this
i love this game so much i've been
playing it for so many years now
and the reason why i love this is
because it's it's a unique and exciting
puzzle game
unlike other games because you end up
collecting these little characters that
are called fiends
and you use these fiends to crack the
puzzle
and once you do that's when you defeat
the slugs
and it's super cute because they have
really great graphics like i genuinely
am so impressed every time i open up
this app i'm like
how do you guys make this look so pretty
but they do and they have
so many levels and also every month they
have
new themed challenges so you'll never
get bored
so best fiends has thousands of levels
already with new levels events and
characters added every month it's hours
of fun right at your fingertips and you
can even play
offline i love that because i have other
games that i try to get into
and you have to you have to be online in
order to everyone
everyone's at home and everyone's using
the same wi-fi so that [ __ ] gets bogged
down
exactly so that's why i absolutely love
best fiends the fact that it's offline
so with over 100 million downloads and
tons of five star reviews
best fiends is a must play download best
fiends
free on the apple app store or google
play that's
friends without the our best fiends
also now that you're home uh now's the
best time to take care of your skin you
guys know how crazy i am about my
skincare you know i wear sunscreen at
home even if i'm not going anywhere yeah
you're a little crazy with yours i think
you should because of the screens yep
the screens or the windows that you walk
by and stuff like i
love skin care and i'm so happy we have
a skincare
sponsor me too right uh we have rory
yay you already know the difference i
mean the importance of taking care of
your skin and everybody wants to fix a
little bit of something some dullness
redness fine lines or acne trying to
find the right treatment can be really
really frustrating but now there's a
simpler smarter solution to get your
skin
the best it's ever been rory is a
digital
health clinic for women uh it's a sister
brand of roman you guys remember roman
reigns yeah yeah like real men they make
it simple to connect with a healthcare
professional online
and see if personalized prescription
skin care
treats the real [ __ ] yeah is good for
you i
i'm on prescription skincare too that's
why all this here i know your skin is
flawless
thank you thank you um and you can do
this all from the comfort of your home
which is also
amazing that's my like rory is my thing
um you don't have to wait for
appointments or even wait in line at a
pharmacy it gets delivered
to you all you have to do is get on your
phone or your computer and complete a
free online consultation
and you'll be and then you'll hear back
from a healthcare professional within 24
hours
if it's appropriate they'll prescribe
you a personalized skin care treatment
plan that works just for you and your
skin
because not everyone is the same um you
don't have to go to the pharmacy
you get it delivered right to your door
with two days shipping and you can also
follow up with your healthcare
professional with questions like
does this product i have clash with this
and make sure they have the right things
for you
now for our viewers if you go to
hellorory.com
big mood you can try out the nightly
defense for just
five dollars it's free to check five
dollars
five doll hairs yeah um it's free to
chat with a healthcare professional and
your first order is just
five doll hairs that's hello rory
r-o-r-y
dot com slash big mood
eligibility requirements and addition
additional terms apply
get it now and also make sure you wear
some sunscreen if you guys want some
good
skin and you guys refuse to wear
sunscreen i don't know what to tell you
your skin's going to suck
thank you look at me and you'll figure
out how you're going to i wish i had
started sooner
so everyone else says thoughts like they
said that you should start as soon as
like 19 18 19 yeah
probably like 10. it's like working out
like um your bones are naturally going
to deteriorate as you get uh
older but you can do the best you can to
protect like slow the deterioration
down they're going to deteriorate no
matter what though so
just slow the process down now i'm a
sunscreen like
fiend right yeah like no like not just
with me like with casey and isaac i'm
like did you put your sunscreen on make
sure i everybody's i literally left it
you're like the mom with the sunscreen
now
they'll thank you later like i actually
feel uncomfortable during the day if i
don't have sunscreen on like walking
through my house
first thing i do in the morning yeah i
wish my mom was harder on us when i was
younger because
everything was just like optional you
know and my mom got skin cancer
and but she's white and so she was just
like you're brown you got enough melanin
and bob marley died of skin cancer oh my
gosh
i'm pretty sure we really can fact-check
so that whole like your brown thing
doesn't really yeah and obviously like i
got this huge like
um sunspot that keeps growing every year
and i've gone to the dermatologist yeah
that's not cancer
no it's not cancer but you have like a
little comma yeah
steve calls it his kiss target
such a sweetie what a dick right i could
lose a high value [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] but
i think that you know him being high
value made me more high value
you know it's like you you're constantly
we're kind of going back and forth with
each other yeah
and that's how the communication goes
better upwards instead of a cycle
downwards exactly like you're not trying
to get back at somebody
it's like how can i be better for them
like oh he did this for me he's always
thinking about me during the day how can
i think about him during the day and
you just kind of want to reciprocate and
you want to grow together
and i think that's the most important
thing that it you know reading
some of the articles i was like it's not
just a gender thing
you know i think that um both gender
you can't just blame men or blame blame
women a lot of it is just growth
um and understanding what behaviors you
have in yourself that are toxic and how
you
can maybe communicate stuff better you
know and
like you were saying about the anxiety
attacks the first time i had a panic
attack in front of steve
he was like yelling at me he was like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what are you
doing what the [ __ ]
and and i was like stop i can't don't
you
yeah and i had to try to explain while
having a panic attack that i just needed
him to hold me and like hug me as
as tightly as possible but yeah it was
it's it's that communication because
then the next time i had one he knew
exactly what to do right away
and if it was just a person that that's
like i don't give a [ __ ] about what you
need like
this freaks me out and i'm going to yell
every time then you know that that's
probably that's not a person for you for
sure because even the other way around
like if you were having a panic attack
and he was yelling at you and you
internalize all of that and you never
express the fact that you are having a
panic attack and what you need
and then you you use the fact that he
doesn't know what you need
against him yeah that's [ __ ] up that's
true that
you're never gonna get anywhere at all
yeah you're literally gonna be stuck in
the same spot and and it's gonna be a
down world
both parties have to want to be on the
same team yeah
yeah i one thing that i realized was um
you know you never really know when
when's the age that you're actually an
adult
and and you never really know like when
you're 25 you think oh i'm an adult now
but i think for me i i don't really feel
like oh i'm actually an adult
until until i was able to be like oh i'm
not always the victim and it's not
always like
you know i'm the person in the right for
every argument it's like oh wait a
minute i have
all of these bad habits i do all of this
stuff and additionally i do have
you know some of these mental health
issues like anxiety and generalized
depression
so it's like once i stopped feeling like
oh this person's just
always doing this to me but then like
your partner has to be able to do that
too so it's like what am i doing wrong
yeah and when you're any age if you
haven't gotten to the place
where you can say this is what i do
wrong then you're still not mature
enough to really even be in a
relationship
and i i established that in the
beginning of my relationships now where
it's like
hey listen like when you're in a
relationship i don't know where you are
maturity wise but you will never i will
never
we will never um do petty things against
each other
you can go and do petty [ __ ]
passive-aggressive [ __ ] to other people
but you're not gonna do that to me
and i'm not gonna do that to you because
we're partners you know some days i'm
gonna make you angry
and you're gonna wanna be like i'm gonna
do this to get back at her but don't do
that because i'm not going to do that to
you either and i will make that
conscious
decision to not do that because you
should be partners and you shouldn't be
trying to get back at each other like oh
will she get yeah she got me angry so
i'm going to do this and that's
really unhealthy builds like resentment
many people
yeah like their partner is their biggest
enemy
exactly what it was because i think for
for at least in my relationship that was
that was the main thing was the fact
that we always viewed each other
as enemies because that i mean that
thing that i just said was really what
was happening where casey didn't know
how to
express his emotions and i'd be
frustrated and i would like
try to like force it out of him but you
can't do that either because i wasn't
very nurturing about it either
so that whole situation was not good
it ends up being like two enemies
against each other and then
it just it's not no one wins the war no
one wins ever and then not until we
went to therapy and like deciding like
hey we need to make a decision same
team and then whenever we get into
arguments and stuff we try to tell
ourselves like in our head like even out
loud like same team
same team remember like we're not good
we're not against each other like yes
we're upset about this thing but
we don't have to take it out on each
other we're still working on it but at
least
we're getting yeah that's huge progress
so it's like [ __ ] because man
yeah we and then it's crazy because i
didn't realize that that's the position
that we ended up
being in the you're my enemy and i need
to get back at you
position slowly happens over years and
then you're like seven years into it and
you're like this whole time we've just
been in a long battle
yeah i feel uh the way that i
communicated to steve the best was
well i didn't want that to ever happen
in our relationship and it had happened
in previous relationships
so anytime i felt like there was a hint
of resentment building
i just voiced it right away i was like
hey you're doing this and it's very
minor and i
i don't want to cause an argument about
it or fight about it but it makes me
feel like
this and i feel myself building
resentment for you
and he would be like oh no like i don't
want any resentment to happen let's talk
it out let's
let's work through this and figure out
what we need most people would never say
that like yeah just hold on to it
carry it yeah let it build no you don't
want to be yeah you don't like you don't
want to be petty or
sometimes you kind of minimize what
you're saying yeah
and so you're like well i don't want to
be that girl that starts an argument
that nags over everything
so i'll just hold it in and then it
builds up over time and then you wonder
why you're not attracted to your partner
anymore or why
like you look at them and you just get
angry and uh and so
yeah i just learned how to like voice
that right away because i loved
him so much i felt like we connected so
much i was like i don't want to lose
this
so anytime i feel a hint of that
building i want to give you it's
basically giving them the option
to make it make things better yeah and
if they don't want to take that
opportunity
to work with you and be on the same team
if they're going to be like
yo you're going to hold you're building
resentment will [ __ ] you like good
or whatever i don't know like if they're
doing something toxic you don't like it
too bad
too bad yeah then then you know like
this isn't worth
investing more time into i did want to
touch on something that might be
a little bit controversial i don't know
but um like we were kind of reading
no i mean not really but as far as like
financial
stability or responsibility like how
much do you guys think that plays
into kind of a quality partner and i
because i know we touched on saying like
oh you don't have to like just look for
a man or woman that's rich right but
like what
how how much does that play into someone
being ready for a relationship or worthy
of a relationship or like
how do you guys feel about that uh i say
it plays a pretty good
part in my relationship simply because
like before when you're young you're
like no
love is all that matters money doesn't
matter we can live in a cardboard box
and be in love and we're happy
and then you grow up and you realize oh
[ __ ] like bills
like and and houses and all this stuff
and like what if we have kids how we're
gonna
feed these [ __ ] idiots you know like
like it becomes like this big thing
where it's and it's it's for me it's
like i don't need you to be rich
but i need you to be financially
responsible
um and i don't like not one person
should carry the whole
burden of your finances unless that's
your
relationship and you like that some men
or even some women or whatever love
being the the breadwinner the provider
that's what makes them feel strong and
their significant other's like you know
what i'm okay with that i can be the
homemaker
but for me i realize as i grew older i
don't want to deal with um
yeah i can't really afford to do that
right now or like because i want to i
want to spread my ring
wings and travel the world and stuff and
i don't want to deal with
yeah i can't do that or like i can't do
this or whatever you know
and that i i would feel like if i
couldn't go because
my partner couldn't that would build a
little bit of resentment too
you know like where are you like get
your life together let's do this
together let's grow let's
you know i have these things that make
me happy and i know you want to come
with me so let's do that why don't you
just be a sugar mama then i
could do that but i can't do that
forever you know that's not my dynamic
that i want
i mean like yeah like when i'm in a
relationship i'm
a huge giver but like there's also i'm
not gonna
complete i can't burn myself out too you
know so it has to be someone that
is also able it's capable is what it is
i need a capable person yeah i think
responsible
is responsible for for me where like
you don't have to be wealthy or rich or
anything but um
being able to pay your bills on time
being able to not just
blow money like have impulse control
like
that kind of stuff i and also having the
same goals like
we both want to go out to a dinner we
both want to go
on a vacation so we're going to have the
same financial goals in mind
um to be able to to have the lifestyle
that we want
um i've definitely like been like most
of my relationships i made more money
than my boyfriend
uh when i met steve steve and i pretty
much trade off years
like i'll make more money one year he
makes more money as a writer he has like
a really like volatile
yeah it's like he makes all of his money
and like lump
huge lump sums and then the next year
maybe not as much
and then the next year huge lump sums
yeah whereas mine's more steady on
monster energy drinks yeah
and kidney stones yeah kidney stones
and we have to just agree on where our
finances are being spent you know
i read that um the number one cause of
divorce is financial issues yeah so
that's why i'm like i
i don't want to just like tap dance
around the issue of money
because it's like it's definitely
important it's actually money has
caused issues in pretty much some of my
well not all of them because some of
them i was too young and it
wasn't even right you know related but
like even say
like with joe like say he had money we
weren't poor but it
the the money was still causing a
problem in some way or another and it's
just like it's just
and now i'm like i'm not gonna [ __ ]
get into a situation where money is
going to be an issue
whether it's like you have more than me
and you're holding it over me
or like i have too much and and you feel
insecure
or you know so like i that's something
that i'm i'm a little bit nervous about
dating i'm like
how am i going to balance like i don't
want to date a hedge fund manager who's
going to be a total [ __ ]
[ __ ] right but then also i don't want
to date someone who's broke
so that's tricky i have that discussion
like
pretty like once i start feeling like oh
this can go somewhere serious
we would have that discussion because i
realized how important it is and it's
also the funny thing is
what came up is how you spend your money
you know
like uh like what are you doing paying
500
for a t-shirt like yeah we can afford it
but why are you doing that and then
i realized that like some future goals
are not aligned
exactly so that's when i realized like i
like someone who
spends their money wisely like sometimes
we can splurge a little bit but
still like we still look for deals yeah
we used to look for deals yeah i mean
you have like the cheapest
living situation in la because you have
roommates and you pay like nothing
but you can afford way more than you pay
for smart
yeah very small gina's over here
stacking cash quietly
that's a smart way to do it yeah i guess
for me and casey we end up
working in the financial department
because
for him uh actually for both of us we
don't necessarily
fixate on it we kind of live at least
for me i live in a life of like i
abundance i got it mm-hmm there's no
worry it's okay it's not that i'm blind
i stopped myself from that but i get
what you mean no but
like i'm not completely blind to my
finances either where i know where we're
at
i know what we can afford also casey and
i are not huge materialistic people we
only buy what we need
yeah it's like yeah i feel like you guys
could have bought a way bigger house oh
[ __ ] yeah we could have
you guys bought a pretty modest house
yeah like youtubers because we didn't
want
we we just we don't need it we we don't
feed it we don't need
to have like crazy elaborate stuff i
mean most people
would look at me and say well you're
driving a tesla what the [ __ ] you don't
need a tesla but it's like well it was
important for
me and like my mental and stay and like
feeling like
whatever i don't have to justify it yeah
we're not we're not
very materialistic and we we handle
ourselves well in our relationship
because
that was actually something that i was
getting worried about when we were
looking into buying a house because
casey
he never looks at our finances and he
lives in a life of like
oh we we just can't afford that we we
can't like we shouldn't we probably
shouldn't spend that's mainly what how
he approaches because he came from like
a gated community in dallas
yeah so he he and he's like oh we can't
afford it
well it's not okay i guess i said it
wrong it's not necessarily that we can't
afford it for him it's like
we don't need to spend that much on that
we can we can just buy
something whatever it is that's how my
my wealthy friends are too like
you stay wealthy by not just spending
frivolously yeah they still look for
deals and stuff they're still using
their bonds even though they're rich
but for him to feel like oh i don't know
like to be worried kind of like that
i don't normally see people that come
from money have a worry kind of
because he didn't act like he wouldn't
actually look at our finances and that's
why he was
he had no idea because he just didn't
even have the full picture so and i'd be
there like it's okay
yeah i've seen our finances we're good
we totally couldn't afford this you're
gonna love it it's okay and we're gonna
get this house and we got it and he's
happy and everything's great but that's
kind of like how we
we end up approaching our finances
though it's where
he's coming from a state of like i don't
really see the full picture but i'm just
gonna
pretend that we don't really have it so
we don't really need to spend it and
then for me it's like
oh this is this is gonna make our lives
easier
let's go for it and then we can afford
it and we're not going over
we're not getting what's the word when
you you get more than what you need
oh yeah you're spending uh i guess no
indulgent
that one like we're not being an
independent or really indulgent yeah
yeah yeah we operate really similarly
too uh
it was the same thing too because i i
run the finances
in our relationship um and when we were
buying a house he was like i don't know
if we can afford it i was like no we're
okay yeah
i think it's smart to because i like the
abundance thing too
i mostly operate in that but only when i
have a plan in place so
if i have a plan in place and like okay
all our bases are covered my
basic needs are being met then this
extra spending money
we can put towards investing which we
both thrive off of that
and then maybe like we'll splurge here
and there and we both like the same
things we like to spend money on
vacations like yeah quality time
together
uh experiences that kind of stuff uh
rather than like having a ball and ass
car or like you know whatever um which
is like
if we were in if c was in the cars then
that could be his
you know splurge but um yeah we both
tend to like the same thing
so it makes it a lot easier that's true
so then that's where
it like back to the whole like finding a
high value partner or whatever it's like
adding the value to your life not it's
something that actually
it's not just adding money to your life
but yeah we're working together towards
a goal yeah and it feels like we both
earned it like
when we're at the end of the day when
we're at on the beach somewhere in a
vacation spot
we both feel like we contributed to that
vacation that's true
that is not saying though that i am
opposed to someone who just wants to pay
all my bills
i'm just same you know no i'm just
kidding you're down for that dynamic not
the other way around
yeah uh like you paying other person if
i was stupid [ __ ] writ well no
because i like the whole like it's just
the priority thing you're you're a baby
though i am baby
so like love comes first and or like uh
and then comes from
yeah love comes first money comes second
oh my god look at what gabby wrote on
the [ __ ]
and i'm not saying say that out loud i'm
gonna say it out loud and you know
i feel like a good match for you jess
would be someone that's like
super funny dragon humor humor you know
and you know i will like find a vintage
you can find them let me see
the name the name cast
does anybody know who kasem g is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you for watching or listening
everybody that's listening
um make yourself a high valued person
because do it for yourself
basically where you are [ __ ] up yes
you attract what you are
think it looks like yeah but trash so i
was nothing but trash but now
i am a high value okay make a list of
all the things that you
like in a person that you want to date
that's a perfect person and make
yourself be there
yes yeah be the change you wish to see
in the world i just made that up
that was beautiful give us five stars we
love you bye bye